Ladies and gentleman, I am Agent B.of MIB with an important announcement.
Thousands of alien bugs have been invading our code.
The invasion threatens our flight navigation systems.
Our financial infrastructure and our ability to play Candy Crush.
[MUSIC]
To fight back, MIB has invented a secret weapon.
The code review and
assembled a crack team of reviewers gather in our headquarters in New York City.
[NOISE] Gentlemen, would you now introduce
yourself to the public, first our moderator.
>> Hello, I am Moderator, sometimes also called the controller.
My name is 3.8.
I'm a professor in computer science, and
they call me 3.8 because it took me 3.8 billion years to evolve.
>> Next, our Reader.
>> Hi, I'm the Reader, Dr. Bug.
They call me Dr. Bug because I smash bugs.
>> Here's our recorder.
>> Hi, I'm Crazy Bob.
They call me Crazy Bob because I'm crazy about Ada.
I'm the tech lead on our avionics project.
We delivered 1.4 million lines of safety-critical Ada code.
>> Next we have Inspector Fra Elbertus.
>> Hi, I'm Fra Elbertus.
I'm the friar of doom.
I was the originator of the sticky net virus when I consulted for
one of those three letter government agencies.
You haven't heard of sticky net because it was so
evil, they had to redo it and call it Stuxnet.
>> And our other inspector, Byte.Me.
>> Hi everyone my name's Byte.Me.
I used to have a back story, but I pseudo RN'd it years ago.
I like coffee, code and Reddit.
That's about it.
>> Finally, I will also be an inspector.
Now ladies and gentlemen, let me show you the first invasion site.
A key piece of software infrastructure called BlankCount.java.
[MUSIC]